[Musique]
Philippe Marini le nouveau président de
la commission des finances et peut-être
le président surprise de cette
commission prestigieuse au Sénat et
l'invité de preuv par 3 bonsoirons merci
d'être avec nous élu UMP donc à la tête
de la commission des finances mais
flanqué bien sûr sur votre gauche par la
nouvelle rapporteur du budget la
socialiste Nicole brick un attelage
inédit que va donc découvrir le Sénat
alors que s'engage la discussion
budgétaire sous la pression de l'agence
moodies qui met notre pays sous
surveillance pour 3 mois et que l'on
connaît bien sûr l'affiche de 2012
Philippe Marini François Hollande face à
Nicolas Sarkozi votre champion mais que
vous avez quand même placé vous sous
surveillance un peu comme une agence de
notation sur le bras de fer budgétaire
qui s'annon ce les questions dans un
instant d'Hervé Asquin de l'Agence
France Presse notre partenaire pour ce
rendez-vous de preuve par 3 et puis sur
les critiques sévères de votre profil
personnel et politique entendu lors de
votre élection il y a quelques semaines
oui vous avez essuyé un tir de barrage
il faut le dire ah oui vous répondrez
aux questions trop court ou trop long
mais il n pas atteint la ça n pas marché
mais quand même vous répondrez quand
même à vos détracteurs et aux questions
tout à l'heure sur ce thème notamment de
perinarna de Public Sénat première
interrogation le projet du Parti
socialiste tel que le défend le candidat
investi François Hollande qui se fait le
chantre de la rigueur budgétaire ce
projet socialiste vous inquiète-il ben
il se fait le chantre de la rigueur mais
il y a deux alors ça ça me plairait
plutôt mais il y a deux choses qui
m'inquiètent beaucoup la première c'est
le rêve réenchanter le rêve français moi
j'ai plutôt tendance à penser que nos
compatriotes il faut leur rem mettre
sérieusement les pieds par terre et que
c'est comme ça qu'on devra s'y prendre
pour refaire tout le chemin que nous
devons faire pour être crédible pour
être un pays respecté pour tenir nos
engagements et assurer la cohésion
sociale c'est pas avec du rêve
c'est-à-dire des promesses qu'on ne
pourra pas tenir c'est pas avec du rêve
qu'on y arrivera donc là j'ai une
première inquiétude à exprimer deè la
deuxième c'est
que notre estimable candidat François
Hollande c'est lancé à corp et perdu
dans les euroobligations les eurobonds
en imaginant que c'est ainsi qu'on
ferait tenir debout l'euro alors que il
pas le seul he on peut dire qu'il y
assez large consensus dans la classe
politique à mon sens c'est une erreur
totale c'est une option impossible car
l'Allemagne ne peut y souscrire et que
rien de monétaire ou d'économique ne se
fera en Europe sans l'Allemagne ça se
fera avec la l'Allemagne à côté d'elle
en partenariat avec elle ça ne se fera
pas dans un monde idéal ou dans un rêve
les eurobonds pour moi c'est du rêve
d'abord parce que l'Allemagne ne peut
pas les pratiquer et la Cour
constitutionnelle de carlrou a il y a
quelques jours publié un jugement très
précis en la matière le bundestac ne
peut pas aliéner sa liberté budgétaire
donc moi ce qui me fait peur en effet
dans le C Hollande qui par ailleurs a
d'excellents côtés et que je respecte
beaucoup mais ce qui me fait peur c'est
premièrement le rêve et deuxièmement la
fuite en avant dans le fédéralisme car
le fédéralisme pour moi c'est le débat
démocratique confisqué dans notre pays
Philippe Mar est-ce que Nicolas Sarkozi
vous fait peur aussi parce que il a
aussi évoqué l'hypothèse des fameux
eurobondes pour aider les pays qui sont
perclus de dett il en a parlé avec
Angela Merkel comme solution de derni
secours les eurobands de toute façon
c'est pas pour aider des pays c'est pour
financer l'ensemble des États de la zone
euro donc les États les plus forts
devraient consentir à une détérioration
de leurs conditions de financement
puisqu'il y a une certaine moyenne qui
s'établirait c'està dire que nous
Français pit notre dette plus cher et
les Allemands encore plus cher attaquez
vous adressez à François Hollande mais
vous vous adressez aussi à Nicolas
Sarkozy alors vous dites ça non pas du
tout pas du tout parce que votre
interprétation pardonnez-moi de vous
dire est inexacte lors des rencontres
chancelières président de la République
on a fait de
l'intergouvernemental et il a été dit
clairement que les eurobandes c'était
pas pour aujourd'hui que c'était en
quelque sorte pour un monde meilleur
mais dans un monde meilleur la paix sera
assurée partout et la cohésion sociale
et la péréquation et la justice règnera
on sera dans un rêve inaccessible d'ici
parce que nous sommes les pieds dans la
Glebe et la boue épaisse on n'est pas
dans un monde C des paroles de la
chancelière du président français pour
rien alors non c'était une direction
parce que vous savez comment me le
disait quand j'étais à sciencepo quand
on ne sait pas faire une conclusion elle
doit toujours être sur l'Europe bon
dites-moi François Hollande est-il pour
vous l'adversaire le plus difficile pour
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est un adversaire
difficile clairement
mais la course de haie que représente la
campagne présidentielle c'est un
exercice de long terme où toute la
personnalité doit s'exprimer avec ses
aspects attachants comme ses aspects les
plus ingrats il faut tenir le coup nous
savons que Nicolas
Sarkozi est en mesure de le faire il l'a
fait il est parti vous le savez
aujourd'hui parce que le soir de la il
est en mesure j'ai dit il est en mesure
en mesure parce que vous avez émis des
interrogations et qui ont été très
remarqué notamment par le principal
intéressé je crois que vous avez échangé
quelques mots je sais pas s'ils étaient
doux ou pas vous avez mis en doute
l'alchimie sarkoze une campagne c'est un
long chemin une campagne pour être élu
président de la République et il y a
beaucoup
d'inattendu dans ce long
chemin d'un côté vous avez un parti le
Parti socialiste un candidat
présidentiel François Hollande qui se
comporte comme si c'était gagné comme si
le sondage était l'élection et de
l'autre vous avez le président sortant
qui est en réalité devenu le challenger
et dès lors qu'il est le challengeer et
qu'il organise sa progression il en est
tout à fait capable il est en mesure de
réussir bon vous êtes optimiste pour lui
non non je dis il est en mesure de
réussir il a une très grande
incertitudce que vous êtes optimiste
pour lu pour moi qui suis affectivement
et amicalement très proche de lui
je pense qu'il va réussir je pense qu'il
va réussir mais pour autant il va
réussir en partant d'une position de
challenger ce qui à mon sens est bien
meilleur pour lui que s'il était si
tranquille sous les ors des résidences
présidentiel donc il va falloir
effectivement que du terrain monte cette
alchimie d'accord du terrain et de lui
aussi évidemment le thème de sa campagne
pourrait être que la vérité sur les
finances publiques ça c'est un bon thème
pour vous alors vous n'aimez pas le le
le rêve français de de François Hollande
là pour le coup ce serait la la la du
réalité des dire la vérité sans
désespérer c'est pas une question
comptable pour moi et c'est tout le sens
de mon engagement politique c'est la
question de savoir si la France va
continuer à exister comme pays
indépendant d'accord ça c'est le thème
de la campagne que doit adopter Nicolas
S à mon sens c'est le sujet crucial
est-ce que nous sommes une petite case
dans les analyses des agences de
notation ou est-ce que nous sommes la
France avec tout son passé son élan et
ce qu'elle signifie pour le monde entier
mais il faut le porter et il faut le
porter avec effort c'est une notion
d'efforts d'efforts indispensables pour
rester nous-mêmes donc vous nous dites
la campagne ce sera sauvons les meubles
mais on se souvient comm en 2007 il y
avait aussi du rêve en 2007 il y avait
du rêve c'était tout est possible là
c'est c'est oublié écoutez
bon pour moi qui est déjà observé depuis
un certain temps la vie politique un peu
participée et je me souviendrai et on le
lui avait beaucoup reproché à cette
époque-là de ce cri de Jacques Chirac à
Cochin l'appel de Cochin après son
accident en corèz et où il
évoquait cette
voie du parti de l'étranger vous voyez
et c'est-à-dire cette voix du
renoncement alors il y a un renoncement
qui nous menace
aujourd'hui ce renoncement
c'est une France qui qui qui qui
soit remise dans le rang des pays
lambda jugés du haut de leur grandeur
par les agences de notation
et dépendantes des enchaînements
irrationnels des marchés pour échapper à
cela donc pour demeurer la France il
faut que nous sachions faire les efforts
nécessaires c'est aussi simple que cela
donc effort pour rester ce que nous
sommes et pour que nos concitoyens
soient fiers d'eux même et fier de leur
pays un mot Philippe Marini sur votre
votre fonction donc désormais de
président de la commission des finances
vous allez cohabiter avec Nicole brick
la rapporteur du du budget le poste que
vous occupiez avant le PS veut faire du
Sénat une vitrine pour ses propositions
économiques vous vous allez vraiment
montrer que vous êtes l'allié de Nicolas
Sarkozi faire acte de résistance en
quelque sorte écoutez c'est pas la reine
d'Angleterre un président de
commission car la liberté de parole est
totale maintenant la parole d'un
Président c'est pas la parole d'un
rapporteur général le rapporteur général
et j'ai beaucoup aimé j'allais dire
presque physiquement j'ai aimé cette
fonction rapportter 13 ou 14 budgets
c'est à chaque instant oui sur chaque
détail sur chaque sujet et le rapporteur
général doit toujours avoir une
argumentation toujours quelque chose à
dire pour faire avancer ses positions
vous un peu plus loin parce que avec
moins d'influence Mo pou Président il
est plus en retrait donc il doit choisir
ses sujet alors il y a des thèmes sur
lesquels j'ai l'intention de travailler
bah la fiscalité de l'immatériel la
fiscalité du numérique l'évolution j'
demander je vous demandais si vous vous
allez engager le combat contre la
nouvelle majorité de gauche mais je
relèverai tout ce qui me semblera
incohérent parce que c'est une majorité
plurielle comme celle de Lionel juspin
donc elle aura des contradictions
internes et sur certains sujet vre
contradiction oui mais je m'efforcerai
de mettre l'accent de porter de temps à
autres le faire sur ce qui peut être une
souffrance de cette majorité plurielle
parce que je ne suis pas sûr que Nicole
BRI soit en mesure de faire passer
toutes ses positions qui pour certaines
me paraissent raisonnables auprès du
Parti communiste et auprès des vers or
la majorité est si étroite qu'il leur
faudra tout le monde faudra discuter
très bien on va parler de tout cela de
ces problèmes budgétaires fiscaux
évidemment de la croissance dans un
instant avec HERV Hasquin de l'Agence
France Presse mais d'abord on va voir
comment pourrait et bien fonctionner
cette cohabitation apparemment elle sera
combative on voit comment elle se se met
en place avec ce reportage de Paul
Bouffard au cœur du Sénat une lutte est
engagée au sein même de la commission
des finances après l'accord global de
gouvernance qui a obligé les socialistes
à donner le poste de président à l'UMP
Philippe Marini va devoir cohabiter avec
Nicole brick sénatrice socialiste et
toute nouvelle rapporteur général du
budget après les sénatoriales le nouveau
président prend quelques jours de
vacances de son côté il en profite pour
s'installer dans son nouveau bureau il a
eu une campagne sénatoriale
rude dans son département donc il a
souhaité se reposer et bon ça vous a
permis de prendre les chose en non j'ai
pas bon moi j'ai fait ce que j'ai à
faire
c'est-à-dire déjà
développer la stratégie budgétaire au
Sénat comme à l'Assemblée nationale les
présidences de la commission des
finances sont de l'opposition différence
majeure au Palais du Luxembourg Philippe
Marini est l'allié du gouvernement
tandis qu'au Palais Bourbon c'est un
socialiste qui préside Jérôme kahusac
affirme qu'un président d'opposition
n'est pas muselé seul motif qu'un
président de commission appartient à
l'opposition d'une
assemblée on imaginerait donc que sa
liberté de parole serait contrainte je
m'inscris en fou contre cette vision des
chos mais au Sénat il est certain que
Philippe Marini va devoir s'accrocher
Nicole brick n'entend pas se laisser
faire c'est un homme qui aime la
confrontation qui aime le débat et qui
sait reconnaître aussi une majorité et
une opposition donc lui il aime l'ajoute
il a des arguments euh j'en aurai alors
évidemment il y aura des pots de banane
il y aura des choses trappes ça c'est la
vie politique voilà donc le combat sera
asserré loyal hein mais tous les coups
ne seront pas permis entre rapporteur
général et président ce ne sera pas un
combat cela peut-être une confrontation
d'idée oui mais il existe un respect
mutuel j'ai apprécié ce que vient dire
Nicole brick et en ce qui me concerne je
la considère comme totalement légitime
dans sa fonction et il n'y a aucune
espèce de raison que la commission des
finances ne demeure pas le lieu de libre
débat qu'elle a été notamment sous Jean
artui allez on aborde tous les sujets
maintenant justement le vif du sujet je
le disais le budget les dettes les
déficites la croissence la fiscalité
avec Hervé Hasquin de l'Agence France
Presse qui nous a rejoint alors c'est
justement monsieur Marini c'est ce qui
fait mal aujourd'hui c'est c'est cette
possible dégradation de la note de la
France de la dette française dans
quelques mois peut-être simounisme mais
ses menaces à exécution le Premier
ministre ce matin a dit que la France
ferait tout le le ministre des Finances
a dit que la France ferait tout pour
conserver son triple AA alors faire tout
ça veut dire quoi faire tout c'est
rester dans les clous c'est-à-dire
respecter sa parole c'est-à-dire euh
être totalement crédible en matière de
prévision de soldes budgétaire et de
cheminement vers les 3 % à la fin de
2013 c'est ça l'instrument de mesure
alors l'instrument de mesure ça veut
dire plus d'impôts ça veut dire plus
d'économie ça va être douloureux les
Français vont devoir mettre la main à la
poche je ne connais pas les économies
totalement indolor alors peut-être
a-t-on une idée de cela dans le rêve à
la française mais moi je ne connais pas
une économie c'est un effort et c'est un
effort pour se qualifier alors on en
sera plus dans quelques semaines
peut-être sur les perspectives de
croissance dès hier soir le Premier
ministre a lâché un chiffre qui est en
dessa de ce qu'il espérait encore il y a
quelques semaines 1,5 % on parlait
jusqu'à présent de 1,75 % c'est très
important parce que ça détermine la
construction du budget ça veut dire quoi
pour le budget une révision à la be
toujours défendu le choix d'une
hypothèse de croissance raisonnable
combien mais ça
dépend de la situation où l'on est je
vous parle en termes généraux soy
précisich grur aller jusqu'au
bout peu importe ce qu'il faut c'est
avoir les marges de manœuvre dans le
budget pour l'ajuster en cours d'année
c'est de ça qu'on a besoin il ne faut
pas faire un budget qui soit si
restrictif qu'il serait de nature à
jouer négativement sur les anticipations
des agents économiques des entreprises
des autres agents économiques car ce
serait une politique de gribouille qui
aboutirait à ce que la croissance soit
de plus en plus faible mais il faut
avoir dans le budget des masses
suffisamment importantes de crédits
bloqués mis en réserve et que l'on
puisse annuler en cours d'année l'outil
de régulation budgétaire doit être
incorporé à la confection du budjet pas
du tout choqué qu'on parte d'une
hypothèse de croissance légèrement plus
élevée que ce que donne le consensus des
économistes mais la contrepartie doit
être d'avoir la marge de manœuvre au
sein du budget pour rester dans les
clous quoi qu'il advienne en clair ça
veut dire que on passe de l'austérité à
la rigueur est-ce que le tabou de la
rigueur doit tomber le gouvernement ne
veut pas entendre parler de ce mot mais
est-ce que le tabou de la rigueur doit
tomber mais on n pas dans un exercice
sémantique il y a une réalité qui est
que si nous ne sommes pas dans les clous
nous pirons notre financement beaucoup
plus cher n'est-ce pas et ça
représentera 5 10 milliards d'euros de
plus chaque année voire davantage et il
faudra faire encore plus d'économie he
que l'on n'imagine pas et je parle à
tous ceux qui nous regardent sur Public
Sénat qu'il existe une solution pour
s'exonérer de la contrainte il n'existe
aucune solution en tout cas aucune
solution indolore pour s'exonérer de la
contrainte il n'y a pas une sorte de dus
ex machina qui va inventer la fiscalité
de rêve dont personne ne se rendra
compte et qui fera rentrer les milliards
dans les caisses quelles sont vos idées
parce que vous n'en manquez pas pour
faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
caisses de l'État HERV par exemple
Nicole brick remet en cause un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été adoptées
par Nicolas Sarkozy qu'est-ce que vous
dites par exemple
par exle sur la Restauration il y a
d'autres exemplesou vous avez dit
qu'elle avait des positions raisonnables
sur quoi elle a-t-elle des positions
raisonnables est-ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin sur la taxe exceptionnelle sur
les sur les haut revenus que ce que le
gouvernement et la majorité ont prévu
jusqu'à présent est-ce qu'il faut une
nouvelle tranche sur l'impôt sur le
revenu pour les ménages les plus aisés
est-ce qu'il faut donc aller plus loin
sur ces questions sur la chasse aux nich
aux niches fiscales oui bien sûr je suis
en attente d'une stratégie fiscale
globale pas de petite recette ou
d'opération politique pour essayer de
mettre le gouvernement en difficulté en
contradiction avec lui-même mais une
stratégie fiscale globale concernant
tous les impôts et dont en effet le
premier élément serait la remise à plat
c'est-à-dire la suppression de la quasi
totalité des niches fiscales
je suis de ceux qui pensent et je l'ai
écrit fin 2006 j'ai pas été écouté je
l'ai écrit fin 2006 dans un ouvrage qui
était antérieur à l'élection
présidentielle 2007 je suis de ceux qui
pensent que la réforme fiscale n'est
acceptable que si elle est globale que
si tout le monde est concerné que si
chacun le lendemain est à la fois
gagnant et perdant de telle sorte que
tous les compteurs soient perturbés et
que tous les lobbyes ne s'y retrouvent
plus fiscal c'est après l'élection
présidentielle il
doit à mon avis naître d'une démarche
d'explication une démarche de vérité et
une démarche qui ne peut aboutir à sa
légitimité que par la sanction du
suffrage vous avez eu 5 ans pour le
faire pourquoi navez vous pas fait
plusutôt écoutez dans ces 5 ans et vous
le savez bien il y a trois périodes il y
a avant la crise il y a la crise et il y
a ce qu'on a appelé post-crise parce
qu'on pense en être sorti en
sous-estimant d'ailleurs les fragilités
de notre système de l'euro h alors pour
revenir au au au démarche raisonnable de
Madame brick qu'est-ce qui pourrait
retenir votre attention est-ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir un terrain d'accord
entre la nouvelle majorité sénatoriale
et l'opposition à laquelle maintenant
vous laquelle vous faites dont vous
faites partie aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir un terrain d'entente
sur l'une ou l'autre des niches fiscales
ou des mesures fiscales alors on peut
converger sur certains sujets mais moi
je suis en attente d'une stratégie
globale et d'ailleurs aussi bien d'un
côté que de l'autre j'aurais à ce stade
un peu tendance à les renvoyer dos à dos
si vous voulez et ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il serait trop facile euh de
tirer prétexte de position que j'ai pu
exprimer de déclarations que j'ai pu
faire pour mettre en difficulté le
gouvernement bon je ne pardon je ne suis
pas vous renvoyez mais vous venez de
renvoyer dos à dos le gouvernement avec
son projet de budget et puis la
gauche j'ai besoin d'une stratégie
globale de quelque chose qui soit
porteur à la fois d'efficacité et
d'équité dans le système fiscal
aujourd'hui qui est capable de
comprendre la logique de notre système
fiscal de prendre position comme avz
vous le demande sur des points précis
par exemple la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires ça coûte
plusieurs milliards d'euros à
l'état rabter un peu je pense qu'on peut
en rabotter un peu la TVA sur la
restauration pe rabter on peut rabotter
aussi il y en a d'autres encore hein
d'autres niches fiscales euh alors il y
a vous ne pouvez arriver à quelque chose
en la matière pardonnez-moi de le dire
que si votre approche est totalement
horizontale que si vous traitez chaque
catégorie bénéficiaire de la même façon
à
égalitéors est- français
e Bâ pourquoi ques sont les
justifications les uns vont arriver avec
leurs arguments sur l'emploi la
formation et cetera les autres avec des
arguments identiques vous n'en finirez
jamais de au nom ce principe au nom de
ce principe d'égalité est-ce qu'il
fallait préserver les restaurateurs
préserver les employeurs sur les
supplémentaires et en revanche taxer les
mutuels les mutuels disent 5 % de plus
sur les contrats l'an prochain c'est
frapper au porte-monnaie les revenus les
plus modestes est-ce qu'il fallait
frapper ces revenus là alors je rappelle
qu'il n'y a pas d'économie indelor je
rappelle que pour rester dans les clous
début septembre il a fallu faire un
collectif budgétaire et il a fallu
additionner des mesures de
rendement et que bon c'était notre
responsabilité de le faire et je
l'assume complètement et je rappelle
aussi que les mutuels ont des frais
généraux ont des sièges sociaux ont des
dépenses de fonctionnement dans lesquels
on pourrait peut-être aussi faire
quelques économies et tout répercutter
automatiquement sur le souscripteur il
me semble que chacun peut faire une
partie du chemin chacun peut faire un
effort c'est pas parce qu'on est une
structure mutualiste qu'on n pas
d'économie à faire sur son train de vie
et sur son mode de fonctionnement mais
là les conséquences on les voit déjà
beaucoup de Français se passent
désormais de de mutuel donc il ça pose
un problème de santé publique mais il
existe la CMU il existe des filets
sociaux dont notre pays par rapport à
d'autres est encore me semble-t-il
relativement généreux hélas bien des
personnes sont dans la peine et dans la
difficulté et doivent frapper à la porte
de tous les guichets sociaux notamment
de nos centres communaux d'action
sociale on le sait bien on voit bien des
situations dramatiques mais pour
autant s'agissant des contrats
solidaires et responsables qui avaient
été munis d'une fiscalité favorable au
moment où il ne s'était pas imposé sur
le marché et à titre incitatif ces
contrats qui aujourd'hui occupent tout
le marché qui leur est disponible et
bien il n'est pas illogique que l'on
revienne sur une incitation fiscale par
la même on voit le caractère pernicieux
pervers de la dépense fiscale pervers
par nature parce qu'une fois qu'on S
installe dans la défense dans la dépense
fiscale il est très difficile d'en
sortir et puis qu'est-ce qu'ils disent
les uns ou les autres qui qu'il soi ils
disent mon avantage n'est pas une niche
monsieur le sénateur épargnez-moi ce
n'est pas une niche fiscale alors la la
dépense fiscale plutôt la ponction
fiscale c'est un peu le concours l'pine
et l'une des dernières idées qui est
sortie c'est cette affaire de taxes sur
les sodats est-ce que vous avez une
opinion sur ce sur ce point est-ce qu'il
faut taxer aussi les boissons alléger
les boissons light bah moi je pense que
les sodas sont diffusés par des euh
multinationales américaines qui peuvent
payer un peu plus d'impôts et que c'est
pas gênant du tout et que par ailleurs
il y a des boissons plus naturelles et
qui sont euh sans doute bien euh
préférables euh sans parler de la
question du surpoids qui on le voit bien
en milieu scolaire et un peu partout eu
guête d'abord les plus modeste donc je
ne suis absolument pas choqué qu'on
fasse un petit peu contribuer monsieur
Coca-Cola qui ne me semble pas être à
plaindre alors oui alors une question
maintenant un peu plus générale sur les
solutions qu'il va falloir trouver pour
essayer de rétablir les finances de la
France bon et il y a des nuages noirs
qui s'accumulent au-dessus de l'économie
française et l'un d'entre eux c'est
cette affaire Dexia la banque francobge
qui est en voie de démantellement qui
est en cours de démantellement l'État
français va apporter sa garantie ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
qui vont être gar anti par l'état
français vous allez devoir voter je
crois mercredi au Sénat sur cette
question est-ce que vous êtes inquiet
c'est une
situation hélas très très problématique
et je pense que le gouvernement français
comme le gouvernement belge font leurs
devoirs notre souci est que l'offre de
financement pour les investissements des
collectivités
territoriales soit maintenu à un niveau
suffisant pour que les projets puissent
se
réaliser notre souci c'est également de
faire jouer à la Caisse des Dépôts comme
à la Banque Postale tout leur rôle c'est
de préserver l'outil remarquable qui est
pour ce pays la Caisse des dépôts et
tout en restant en conformité avec le
droit européen donc ce n'est pas un
exercice
facile ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative va être le baptême du feu
de la nouvelle rapporteur générale et je
forme vraiment euh des souhaits euh pour
que le travail qu'elle a entrepris
aboutisse à un bon débat et autant que
faire ce peu à une version semblable à
celle de l'Assemblée nationale h voilà
merci
her pour ces questions vous avez dit que
donc il on n'échappera pas à l'effort
hein euh Philippe Marini vous l'avez dit
donc à la rigueur pourtant l'austérité
menace la
croissance c'est ce que dit le prix
Nobel Joseph slitz donc il dit que
l'austérité ça ne marchera pas il faut
faire attention aussi qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça i je sais pas ce que
propose Monsieur Joseph Stiglitz
n'est-ce pas alors est-ce qu'il propose
de laisser filer la dépense publique
est-ce qu'il propose de faire d'autres
impôts et alors est-ce qu'il est amateur
de la taxation mondial sur les
transactions financières comment
pense-il l'imposer à tous les pays du
monde à commencer par le sien là encore
on se fait de grandes réputations à bon
compte n'est-ce pas c'est des heures de
consultants ou de déclarations très cher
payé en général pour des messages assez
faciles et assez anodins me semble-t-il
quand on a cette réputation à mon avis
il faudrait aller un peu plus loin dans
la recherche de solutions d' alors phipe
je le disais tout à l'heure vous avez dû
faire face à de nombreux détracteurs oui
lors de votre élection à la tête de
cette présidence ils sont nombreux vous
allez pouvoir répondre leur répondre
répondre également à perintarna dans un
instant un véritable tir de barrage
c'est pas l'accord politique hein qui a
été passé entre la nouvelle majorité du
Sénat et l'UMP qui est en cause mais
c'est bien vous qui étiez visé comme
nous le rappelle tamtr nuit Philippe
Marini c'est le dernier des Mohicans le
seul président de commission issu de la
nouvelle opposition bref l'unique
gagnant de droite du Sénat de gauche et
dans la nouvelle majorité ça fait
grincer bien des dents j'ai mes
préférences elles ne vont pas à Philippe
Marini il aurait fallu trouver quelqu'un
d'irréprochable j'avais entendu parler
d'une république irréprochable de l'UMP
aurait été sage de proposer un autre
candidat que Monsieur Marini pour ce que
je sais de quelques rumeurs qui traînent
dans l'Oise il faut dire que dans son
fief PHPP marign est associé à l'affaire
de la vente de l'hippodrome de Compiegne
57 hectares de forêt cédé pour 2 million
et demi d'euros de gré à gré à la
Société des courses alors que le terrain
est évalué entre 15 et 25 millions
d'euros un cadeau jugé scandaleux pour
lequel il est aujourd'hui mise en cause
mais améia part on pointe aussi du doigt
des avantages fiscaux sur des sommes
bien supérieures accordés par exemple
aux sociétés d'investissement immobilier
et ces sociétés qui vendaient leurs
biens avec des plusvalués et cetera ont
pu euh ne pas payer l'impôt du tout sur
les bénéfices à la condition qu'elle
reverse l'ensemble des des profits
qu'elles avait fait à leur à leur
propriétaire sous forme de dividende
c'est quelque chose qui a dû coûter
quelque chose comme 20 milliards au
budget de l'État sur sur une période de
5 ans l'amendement selon Martine orange
a été directement rédigé par les lobby
fonciers enfin le nouveau président de
la commission des finances a plusieurs
cordes à son arc en plus de son travail
parlementaire il siège dans les conseils
d'administration et de surveillance de
nombreuses sociétés privées son cas a
été remonté jusqu'au Conseil
constitutionnel quand même pour savoir
s'il pouvait occuper tel ou tel poste et
jusqu'où allit le conflit d'intérêt bref
surtout en pleine rigueur budgétaire
Philippe Marini n'était pas exactement
le profil attendu pour la fonction il
est encore là où on ne l'attendait plus
ce qui ne doit pas lui déplaire voilà
Philippe Marini alors oui bonsoir
Philippe Marini est-ce que ça au
contraire est-ce que ça vous plaît cette
image ou vous avez été au contraire
choqué par cette levée de bouclier
contre vous écoutez quand on est
critiqué chez ses
adversaires on devient plus solide chez
ses amis et croyez-moi toutes ces
critiques on on on on on ont créé euh un
climat encore plus favorable qu'il ne
l'aurait été pour que je sois désigné à
l'unanimité par mes amis politiques hein
parce que euh euh euh c'est un peu
facile de dire je veux bien donner à
telle foration politique mais pas
celui-là alors il est assez normal que
dans la famille politique dont il s'agit
on fasse le raisonnement selon lequel on
est assez grand pour désigner qui est
apte à porter dans le débat l'image et
les intérêts de son groupe mais
justement est-ce que cette image de
parlementaire à la solde des lobby
financiers la solde des lobis ça ne vous
gêne pas mais c'est le mensonge le plus
le plus le plus immense que l'on puisse
imaginer tout le monde sait
que j'ai très rarement été disponible
intellectuellement pour les demandes par
exemple de la Fédération Bancaire
Française n'est-ce pas
qui il y a déjà assez
longtemps se battait contre les
privilèges fiscaux de certains réseaux
hein avec les livrets d'épargne
administré et puis qui a cessé de le
faire quand la dit fédération c'est
ouverte au
groupes à structure à structure
mutualiste ou coopérative et j'ai
toujours
été très réservé par rapport à ces
positions corporatives de même pour la
Fédération française des sociétés
d'assurance je suis un des très rares à
dire que le régime fiscal de l'assurance
vie va devoir évoluer et évidemment
c'est pas la parole officielle de la
FFSA sur les C sur les CS les
amendements en question ont été rédigés
à
l'époque en effet de 2000 2002 2003
entre la direction de la législation
fiscale leab cabinet d'Alain Lambert et
moi-même comme rapporteur général jamais
mon stylo n'a été tenu par quelqu'un
extérieur au
Sénat Philippe Marini quand on est
rapporteur du budget aujourd'hui
président de la commission des finances
est-ce qu'on peut également être
administrateur de société c'est possible
ça mais certes oui car c'est permis par
le Code électoral il y a une procédure
tout à fait précise en la matière quand
il y a doute on va chercher le Conseil
constitutionnel il y a rien de plus
transparent et en outre cons constionn
vous aé
de ne me gêne pas il fallait que la
question soit posée que la jurisprudence
soit faite et et et et ça ne me gêne
rien c'est parfaitement transparent mais
ce sont tout de même des activités
rémunérées ce sont tout de même des
activités rémunéré alors est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas de conflit d'intérêt il n'y a
pas de conflit d'intérêt car ceci est
sans lien avec mon activité législative
et croyez-moi j'y veille et euh il y en
a bien d'autres autour de moi qui
veillent encore davantage mais euh quand
on parle des
entreprisesadr quand on parle des
entreprises ou quand on parle de
fiscalité quand on parle de la vie
économique alors est-ce qu'il faut
rester dans sa bulle complètement éterée
alors où on dépend complètement de
l'information qui vous arrive et qui
n'est jamais neutre l'information n'est
jamais neutre où est-ce qu'il faut euh
essayer de comprendre un petit peu par
soi-même les rouages vous savez c'est
très précieux d'être pour une toute
petite partie de son temps encore en
lien avec l'entreprise avec la vie
économique avec le secteur privé c'est
très précieux parce qu'on comprend
beaucoup mieux les modes de raisonnement
et ce qui se passe réellement on est
très vite coupé de toute réalité dans ce
pays Philippe Marini une conséquence du
passage à gauche du Sénat est-ce que
votre ville de compienne va devoir se
passer de la réserve parlementaire que
chaque année vous octroyez au budget
municipal il n'y a aucune espèce de
raison de mon point de vue que les
règles du jeu qui représentent une
tradition
républicaine existant longer les règles
du jeu une somme à peu près de 50
millions 58 millions d'euros qui sont
répartis entre les sénateurs mais de
façon assez inégalitaire donc peut-être
va-t-il falloir revoir ces règles du jeu
de façon égalitaire entre les groupes en
fonction de leurs effectifs ensuite il
appartient au groupe de prendre ses
décisions mais alors selon la Cour des
comptes qu'on Pienne bénéficier 2
million et de par me dites pas que tous
les sénateurs ont cette manne financière
chaque année à donner à leurs communes
ou aux communes avoisinant tout cela est
extrêmement transparent délibéré en
conseil municipal
euh le contrôle de régularité est là à
tous niveaux et et et et et je suis en
effet plutôt fier d'avoir grâce à
cela accélérer amplifier la réalisation
par exemple euh d'une bibliothèque d'un
musée mémorial de la déportation et de
l'internement sur le camp de royaleu qui
n'aurait probablement pas pu être fait
croyez-moi il n'y a là-dedans que de
l'intérêt général qui va piloter
aujourd'hui cette réserve parlementaire
au Sénat c'est la majorité de gauche
c'est Jean-Pierre Bell c'est Nicole
brick à la commission des finances
écoutez pour moi les règles du jeu euh
qui prévalaient ont tout lieu de
perdurer et au demeurant pense pas que
l' nouveau président du Sénat va vouloir
revoir et la répartition et
l'utilisation de cette réserve
parlementaire écoutez pour moi c'est un
sujet euh qui fait partie de la culture
de l'institution qui est d'ailleurs euh
qui a d'ailleurs un traitement tout à
fait voisin à l'Assemblée nationale et
je ne vois pas pourquoi et on
critiquerait davantage sén que
l'Assemblée nationale vous n'z pas
anticipé un trou dans votre budget
municipal de toute façon je suis habitué
à faire avec les ressources que j'ai
donc s'il y a plus de ressources on fait
plus de projets s'il y a moins de
ressources on fait moins de projet on
imagine qu'en tant que président de la
commission des finances vous allez
encore avoir une réserve parlementaire
assez élevé non c'est votre espoir c'est
votre espoir écoutez si c'est pour
financer des projets d'intérêt
général alors que l'on en a bien besoin
in et c'est le cas oui il faut souhaiter
disposer de ressources qui permettent de
répondre à des besoins et à des attentes
et que ce soit dans des communes
relativement importantes comme la mienne
ou dans les plus petites communes mais
vous savez dans le mandat précédent mon
ami et collègue socialiste André vantô
faisait mine de s'inquiéter de cette
situation alors que lui
distribuait les subventions du Conseil
Général et c'est 50 millions d'euros par
an alors il me cri critiquez- mooi pour
quelques
malheureux dizaines ou centaines de
milliers d'euros et lui il en
distribuait 50 et il le faisait en
faisant entrer pour une part un peu de
politique politicienne comme il se doit
n'est-ce pas donc donc donc je crois que
ce type d'attaque venant en particulier
de mon département serait tout à faait
indécent parce qu'il vaut mieux
additionner les efforts plutôt que de se
vouer au gémonies les uns les autres ce
sera par cohabitation personnalité un
oui je voulais surtout peut-être dire un
petit mot de de la Syrie Philippe Marini
vous avez fait plusieurs voyages en
Syrie vous avez rencontré à plusieurs
reprises Bachar al-Assad est-ce que vous
continuez à penser qu'il doit se
maintenir au pouvoir malgré les
violences cez j'ai lu avec grand
intérêt dans un journal du soir daté
d'hier les déclarations du dissident
historique Michel kilot ancien
communiste de passage à Paris et 10 ans
en substance
la guerre civile menace mon pays
qu'est-ce qu'il faut préférer la guerre
civile ou la réforme même si elle est
très partielle alors c'est quelqu'un qui
a été emprisonné à deux reprises qui
connaît bien son pays sa réalité et sa
diversité moi j'aurais plutôt tendance à
lui faire confiance davantage qu'à des
lobby américains ou à des journalistes
qui ne connaissent lob américains on l'
vu dimanche la Ligue AR qui s'est réuni
au tour justement du cas de la Syrie qui
appelle Dioma française et la diplomatie
française ils appellent tous Bachar
alAssad à se mettre à la table des
négociations pour essayer de trouver une
issue à cette crise pour l'instant il
fait la sour d'oreille Bachar
al-Assad je ne suis pas retourné en
Syrie depuis janvier
2010 tout ce que je sais sur ce pays
aujourd'hui c'est par les
journaux éventuellement par quelques
visites d'amis Syriens à Paris
et je pense qu'en effet euh
la situation est une
situation qui ne saurait durer et vous
ne contestez pas ce que dit Alain Jupé
notamment que la Syrie se rend coupable
vis-à-vis de son peuple de crime contre
l'humanité est-ce que la Chine ne s'est
jamais rendu coupable de crime contre
l'humanité je veux dire est-ce que le
Dali Lama vaut plus de considération ou
moins de considération que le Conseil
national syrien moi je me permets de
poser toujours la même question aussi
dit je ne saurais justifier aucune
pratique
qui serait la négation des droits de
l'homme et des valeurs auxquelles nous
croyons bien entendu une dernière
question autour de de votre personnalité
pour finir quand vous avez évoqué le
soir des sénatorial sur notre plateau
d'éventuel recours à droite candidature
de recours à droite pour la
présidentielle vous en parliez tout à
l'heure avec Michel est-ce que c'était
de la maladresse dû à la déception de la
défaite ou est-ce que au contraire vous
contrôlez tout à fait votre parole vous
savez quand on est amené à parler
beaucoup surtout dans une émission de 45
minutes bon euh bon euh ça peut déraper
ben il y a il y a bon c'est pas facile
d'être toujours très contrôlé quand même
quand même vous vous aviez remis en
cause la légitimité de Nicolas SAR pas
du tout ça c'est une interprétation tout
à fait tout à fait fallacieuse je n'ai
absolument pas dit cela je n'ai
absolument pas pensé que vous allez
faire beaucoup plus attention maintenant
que vous avez été désigné par l'UMP pour
être président de cette commission ça
vous oblige à faire plus attention je me
trouve dans une situation différente je
ne suis plus le rapporteur général tête
chercheuse
ou animateur d'un laboratoire d'idées je
suis un responsable politique auquel son
groupe a fait confiance dans une période
très
pré très préélector
bon vous savez on
peut gratter dans la majorité peut on
peut trouver ça dépend des sujets ça
dépend des moments et puis vous savez
bon on m'a quand même fait confiance en
sachant qui je suis je ne suis pas un
perd de l'année bon et on m'a fait
confiance parce qu'on pense que dans un
débat je peux peut-être apporter quelque
chose et avoir un peu de spontanéité une
touche personnelle vous n'en avez pas
manqué lors de cette émission Philippe
Marini Merci à VOUS bonsoir à tous à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
merci